>>> JUST IN THIS MORNING,
FACEBOOK'S PARENT COMPANY META
ANNOUNCED THAT IT HAS SHUT DOWN
TWO SEPARATE NETWORKS OF FAKE
ACCOUNTS RUN FROM CHINA AND
RUSSIA.
THE ACCOUNTS WERE ENGAGED IN
COVERT INFLUENCE OPERATIONS AND
EVEN POSED AS AMERICANS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM,
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE COMPANY.
WITH ME NOW, CNN CORRESPONDENT
DONIE O'SULLIVAN WHO COVERS THIS
SO CLOSELY, EXPLAIN WHAT WAS
JUST ANNOUNCED, DONIE.
>> QUITE A BIT TO UNPACK HERE,
JOHN.
FIRST TO THE CHINESE ACCOUNTS.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT IN BOTH
CASES OF CHINA AND RUSSIA,
FACEBOOK META IS SAYING --
THEY'RE NOT SAYING IT IS FROM
THE GOOFTGOVERNMENTS OF THOSE
COUNTRIES, THEY'RE NOT SAYING
WHAT SPECIFIC ENTITY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CHINESE
ACCOUNTS, THERE WAS A TINY
NUMBER OF ACCOUNTS WITH VERY
LITTLE IMPACT AT ALL, BUT THEY
WERE POSING AS AMERICANS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE POLITICAL DIVIDE.
AND THE REASON META IS SAYING
THAT IS IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE
THEY SAY THEY HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
SORT OF BEHAVIOR COMING OUT OF
CHINA BEFORE.
THEY HAVE SEEN IT, OF COURSE,
WITH RUSSIA AND INFAMOUSLY WITH
THEIR TROLL FARM AND WHAT NOT.
WE SPOKE TO BEN NEMO LAST NIGHT,
ONE OF THE SENIOR PEOPLE ON THE
TEAM LOOKING INTO THIS AT META
AND THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> A SMALL OPERATION, AND IT
DIDN'T SEEM TO GO TO ANY
MEANINGFUL AUDIENCE.
IT IS FIRST TIME WE HAVE SEEN AN
OPERATION FROM CHINA REALLY LIKE
THIS FOCUSED ON TARGETING U.S.
POLITICAL DEBATES AND WE'RE ALL
ON HIGH ALERT AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
THEY WERE RUNNING FAKE ACCOUNTS
THAT PRETENDED TO BE AMERICANS
AND TRIED TO TALK LIKE
AMERICANS.
AND THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
REALLY DIVISIVE DOMESTIC ISSUES
LIKE ABORTION AND GUN CONTROL.
THAT'S A REAL STEP CHANGE FROM
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
>> SO WE SHOULDN'T BE HAIR ON
FIRE CHINA IS METTLING IN
AMERICAN ELECTIONS IN THE
MIDTERMS, BUT WHAT FACEBOOK IS
SAYING IS THEY WANT TO PUT THIS
ON PEOPLE'S RADAR, THIS IS
HAPPENING, THIS IS WHAT THEY
FOUND AND THEY PASSED THIS
INFORMATION ON TO THE FBI.
QUICKLY ON THE RUSSIA CAMPAIGN
WAS FAR BROADER, VERY
SOPHISTICATED, FOCUSED ON
PUTTING -- PUSHING MESSAGING
ABOUT UKRAINE.
$100,000 SPENT ON FACEBOOK ADS
ON THE PLATFORM, MORE THAN 2,000
FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS AND PAGES AND
NOT ONLY ACTIVITY ON FACEBOOK.
THEY WERE MIMICKING WESTERN NEWS
OUTLETS.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS REAL
ARTICLE HEADLINE FROM THE
GUARDIAN, WHICH WAS -- THIS IS
JUST A HEADLINE THAT THEY HAVE
ON THEIR WEBSITE EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
AND THEN FAKE HEADLINE WHICH
POPPED UP, THEY BUILT A WHOLE
FAKE WEBSITE TRYING TO MAKE IT
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE BUCHA
MASSACRE TRYING TO MAKE IT SEEM
THAT REAL NEWS OUTLETS WERE
PUSHING THE NARRATIVE AND THEY
WERE BUILDING THESE ENTIRE
WEBSITES TO LOOK LIKE THE
GUARDIAN'S WEBSITE SO QUITE
SOPHISTICATED STUFF THERE.
>> HOW LONG -- EVERY TIME -- IT
IS A GOOD THING, RIGHT, WHEN
FACEBOOK CATCHES THIS, I DO
WONDER HOW LONG THEY HAVE BEEN
OPERATING AND IF THEY COULD HAVE
BEEN CAUGHT SOONER.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, LOOK, YOU SEE THERE THAT
WITH THE RUSSIA CAMPAIGN, THEY
SPENT $100,000 ON FACEBOOK ADS.
LOOK, WE DO SAY A LOT -- THERE
IS A LOT SURROUNDING FACEBOOK.
A LOT WRONG WITH META AND MARK
ZUCKERBERG AND NICK CLEGG, ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN IT THAT ARE
OUT OF TOUCH, BUT THIS SPECIFIC
TEAM THAT WORKS AT FACEBOOK,
ROOTING OUT THESE INFLUENCE
CAMPAIGNS RUN FROM OTHER